- So earlier we were talking about music.
So I have to ask what
are some songs you go
to when you're down?
- Wet Ass (beep) um
(Kelly laughs)
(audience and Gwyneth laugh)
- Oh my God
oh my God
I can't even
Oh my God I'm done
I'm done
That was
I literally
I need to see the tape back.
Cause I was like I felt
like I was like, Oh, wait
what?
I'm sorry
That was amazing!
Oh
God, you win for favorite
guest this season.
- Oh my God
- No, that was amazing.
I needed that in my soul.
Well, everyone wants to know this.
So tell us about your self-care routine
because you look well,
like you looked at 22
so we're all kind of mad about that.
So can you tell us what's happening?
- Yes. Well, you know, I
I mean I think it's a multi-pronged
approach, right?
I think that it's really important to
exercise, sweat, hydrate,
sleep well, be happy,
you know, walk and breathe fresh air.
I really do think all of that is part
of a great beauty routine,
especially, you know
eating foods that have,
you know a lot of nutritional density.
And then I have amazing scoop
of skincare that we make at GOOP
that I love and use.
And we've worked really
hard to make efficacious
good products that are clean or non-toxic,
- Yeah
and, and then you know,
like for a little bit
of extra help, you know
I've been, I'm the global ambassador
for Merz aesthetics.
They have a little, you know
anti-wrinkle injection that
for right between the eyes.
So that helps as well.
- Wait, did that hurt?
- No, no. It's a teeny
little, one little needle.
- Okay.
- It's not so bad.
- No, I can get myself like a little shot
like a B12 or something like that.
I can do that, but I, but I don't know.
I get weird about, I feel
like I, I don't know.
I'd messed that up.
- Well you don't do it yourself.
You have to go to a doctor.
- Oh oh
Okay.
- Yeah
- That's amazing though.
All the things that you said are great
especially with all the,
I love that about your company
that you care about,
all the chemicals that you don't use.
Like, I think that that's really all
very important for not just individuals,
but as a society.
- Yeah and you know it's been amazing
when I started the company GOOP
whatever it was 12 years ago
and I was talking about clean beauty
and organic products.
And, you know, it was very early on
and people were like what is this weird,
you know, hippie stuff.
And now it's so incredible
to see the consumer
caring so much about non-toxic products
with what we absorb so much
of what we put on our skin.
And it's just been amazing
to see the consumer
start to shape the behavior
of these big companies.
And now they have to step
up and clean up their act.
And so it's really nice to have been
a little part of that.
- Yeah.
The demand is there.
So the supply must be agreed.
Well, having created an empire
what advice do you have for
women starting out businesses?
- I applaud any woman who
wants to start a business
because even acknowledging
that is an amazing feat
in a culture where, you
know, for many generations
women have been taught
kind of implicitly not
to be entrepreneurial.
And so if I feel like if
if a woman has that
strong voice inside of her
that she feels called to do something
she should absolutely do it.
And I think looking back
would I have done differently
I would have tried to
learn more upfront instead
of learning so heavily on the job.
And I would have
I would have like created
a proper business plan
and started calling mentors earlier.
And, and, and just that, and, you know
I just think set yourself up for success.
It's beautiful that you are acknowledging
that you want it and anything is possible.
I really believe women
are incredibly powerful
and that can manifest anything
you put their mind to.
(audience applause)
- I agree.
And I think it's interesting
that you said you
wish you wouldn't have learned
as much just on the job
but I think a lot of
kids are even like that.
Some people are, you know
they can learn by listening to
people or reading something.
And a lot of other
people have to be able to
like getting their hands
dirty and getting there
and being more of like
an apprentice situation.
So I don't know.
I think it,
it worked out it's perfect how you did it
way to go.
- Well, you know,
I think it's just the
way it happened for me.
And, you know, I just made
a lot of mistakes, but
but that was part of my process as well.
- Yeah. And that's okay.
That's what I think is the
best thing to tell people too.
It's okay.
I think everybody doesn't
want to make mistakes.
It's like, well, without the mistake
you wouldn't learn where you shouldn't go
and where you should go.
So it's been so awesome.
That was the best answer
anyone's ever given on this show.
As far as the song
- Now I usually like saved my sense,
my sense of humor for behind closed doors.
But I guess quarantine's
just brought it out of me.
- You're just, let it
out Gwyneth, let it out.
Cause it's awesome.
I literally needed that laugh.
It was like a full like belly laugh.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
I love you so much.
You're welcome on the show anytime we are
big fans of you here.
- I love you too. You're amazing.
And also what doesn't
kill me makes me stronger.
- It's not as good as wet ass
(beep), but it's all right.
(laughs)